I'm quoting example too because we did
have a one period one and we're dealing
with what happens when you've got your V
squared right but you need to go further
and find X right now if you want to get
X you're gonna have to integrate again
but you can't really do it v square
we've got to integrate V on its own so
we're gonna deal with that as we go
through the questions okay so for
starters this is just the simple part
using our result let's see how good your
memory is four four we define the
acceleration and we're wondering in
terms of not time but displacement okay
and there was a derivative also he
remembers what's on the right hand side
take some that equals okay the
derivative with respect to X right
because again it's all in terms of sorry
well in terms of displacement and not
time the derivative off there what was
this awkward bit that was in here this
about velocity half V squared right
and you remember where it comes from
it's the integral of V right without the
constant we have to worry about okay now
there's that resolve and we would prove
that okay so let's use it now would be
given an equation for x dangan okay so
the way it begins is just by QWERTY this
result and substituting for whatever is
also good bad so I'm gonna have on the
left hand side and that's 3x squared
that's what they've told me in the
beginning right so this point I'm going
to integrate with respect to X the right
hand side is and this business with
respect to X so I'm going to get where
half the squared 3x squared integrating
with respect to X is going to turn into
X cubed right by the way can you see now
why all those months ago I was trying to
emphasize that we should write the
proper derivatives not just why - right
because you're gonna have a lot of these
different letters flying around and it
totally changes the meeting it's a
different table
one thing versus another when we get the
time all right so then that executes and
of course you've got to have your
constant there as well okay so far so
good now in order to get V squared on
its own without this pesky cluster in
the way let's uh simplify this and now
which which details should we get to
find out what the constant is well I've
got V X sir I need some kind of
condition that relates those together so
I guess I'd go with this one
the time will come into the picture
later so velocity minus square root of 2
okay so this on the right left hand side
is just going to be there's the negative
will square out and on the right hand
side we've got 2 times 1 cubed 0 and so
now I can write my formula for B squared
it's just to excuse